the conservative party have confirmed
about that they have fears about cyber
hackers in the last few minutes the
conservative party has told sky news we
have consulted with the national cyber
security center throughout this process
that's the voting process and have
decided to enhance security around the
ballot process
eligible members will start receiving
ballot packs this week while tory hq
have also released a letter that's been
sent to party members all 160 000 or so
of them
warning them that the process has been
delayed and the need for increased
security the letter says thank you for
your patience uh your ballot now is on
the way but we'll arrive at you a little
later than we originally said don't
worry this is because the letter says to
members we've taken some time to add
some additional security to our ballot
process which has delayed us slightly
and it talks about when you receive your
pac you can vote online or by post and
it then it goes on to say if you have
not received your ballot by thursday the
11th of august please email the tory
party and he talks about how it's an
offense to vote more than once and uh
if you do you'll have your party
membership withdrawal this letter is
from sean duckworth who is the head of
membership for the conservative party
now
the warnings have come from this uh
national cyber security center that is
part of gchq the uk's listening post and
the daily telegraph is uh
reporting that the gchq warned that
cyber hackers could change people's
ballots and the telegraph also says the
tories have been forced to abandon plans
uh which many uh people thought were
unwise anyway to allow members to change
their vote for the next leader the
telegraph quotes um a spokesman for the
national cyber security center saying
defending uk democratic and electoral
process is a priority for the ncsc and
we work closely with all parliamentary
political parties local authorities and
mps to provide cybersecurity guidance
and support and the quote goes on as you
would expect from the uk's national
cyber security authority we provided
advice to the conservative party on
security considerations for online
leadership voting so that's what the
security people are saying tory hq have
confirmed that they've
had consultations with the gchq uh
people the cyber security experts and
have decided to enhance security and
admitting to members there is going to
be a delay you'll recall of course that
china russia and iran have been accused
of interfering in elections around the
world there were accusations of
attempts to interfere in the 2020 u.s
presidential election well uh this is uh
quite a twist uh an unexpected twist in
the drama of the tory leadership
election the threat of cyber attacks
cyber hacking being taken very seriously
by the tory party so much so that the
the issuing of ballot papers has been
delayed although they are insisting they
will go out later this week